La science était vraiment au service du public.
Tel était mon but en choisissant mes études.
Je souhaitais consacrer ma vie à ça.
Donc, cette coalition improbable
entre des citoyens, des pasteurs, des journalistes et des scientifiques,
s'est constituée pour dévoiler la vérité grâce à la science,
la revendication et le militantisme.
Un pédiatre local a pu déterminer
que les cas d'empoisonnement au plomb chez les enfants avaient doublé
à Flint depuis le début de la crise.
L’État du Michigan a dû reconnaître le problème
et prendre des mesures correctives.
Ce regroupement, et bien d'autres ont pu protéger les enfants de Flint.
Quelques mois plus tard,
le président Obama a visité la ville et déclaré l'état d'urgence fédérale.
Aujourd'hui, Flint reçoit plus de 600 millions de dollars
en soins de santé, nutrition, éducation,
et pour réhabiliter le système des eaux.
Toutefois, l'arrogance et le mépris impitoyable pour la santé publique
des scientifiques et des ingénieurs des agences gouvernementales
est simplement incroyable.
Ces cultures malsaines se repaissent au sein de tels groupes,
là où on ne pense qu'à respecter les règles et cocher des cases,
au dépens de protéger la santé publique.
C'est consternant.
Regardez ce passage d'un e-mail
d'une employée de l'agence de protection de l'environnement :
« Je crains que Flint ne mérite pas que nous prenions des risques. »
Clairement, il y a une déshumanisation de toute la population.
A présent, écoutez la première règle des sciences de l'ingénieur,
qui, à mon avis, devrait être la première loi de l'humanité :
« Considérer avant tout la santé, la sécurité et le bien-être public, »
par-dessus tout.
Tel est notre Serment d'Hippocrate, bien qu'il soit rarement reconnu,
et encore moins accepté.
Quand des scientifiques et des ingénieurs, comme leurs confrères médecins,
font des erreurs, des gens en subissent les conséquences,
et parfois, ils meurent.
Si nos professionnels et nos étudiants ne comprennent pas ça,
c'est la société entière qui en paie le prix.
Aux tréfonds de l'histoire, il y a un personnage que j'admire beaucoup
et qui s'appelle Peter Palchinsky.
Il a vécu au temps de l'Union soviétique.
Palchinsky a eu des ennuis répétés à cause de son honnêteté radicale,
et de sa volonté de pointer du doigt les failles de la poursuite aveugle
d'une industrialisation rapide par les soviétiques.
Tout le monde devait suivre les ordres venus d'en-haut.
Toutes les remarques ou questions étaient malvenues.
Les Soviétiques avaient créé la plus grande armée d'ingénieurs au monde.
Cependant, ils n'étaient que des rouages d'une machine titanesque vouée à l'échec.
Palchinsky par contre, implorait les ingénieurs
d'envisager les conséquences économiques, politiques et sociales de leurs actes,
en d'autres mots, de se focaliser sur le public.
Sa voix de la raison, courageuse, était considérée comme une menace
par l'institution politique.
Joseph Staline a ordonné son exécution en 1929.
La vision des technocrates qu'a Palchinsy est très différente
de celle qui reste populaire et très habituelle aujourd'hui :
un chercheur froid qui travaille dans une tour d'ivoire, son laboratoire,
ou un ingénieur coincé, bossant dans son petit poste de travail.
Brilliant, certes,
mais isolé du monde,
montrant peu d'émotions,
une espèce de Docteur Spock dans « Star Treck ».
Ce mec-là.
(Rires)
Risquons-nous un salut à la Spock !
Pas certain que j'y arrive.
De fait. Impossible d'être Spock.
Heureusement que je ne peux pas devenir Spock.
(Rires)
Cette différence m'a été remémorée par un article récent,
publié dans un journal scientifique très respectable,
qui qualifiait notre travail à Flint comme empreint d'un « idéalisme jeune »,
et « de sentiments dramatiques hollywoodiens ».
Il appelait les scientifiques à protéger les fonds de recherche
et les institutions,
à n'importe quel prix, peu importe la validité de la cause.
Si vous avez le sentiment de devoir vous engager dans une cause,
même une urgence,
il est préférable de trouver une organisation à but non lucratif,
et d'obtenir le support entier de la communauté académique,
quoi que ça puisse signifier,
avant de s'engager.
Aucune mention de notre obligation morale et professionnelle
d'empêcher de nuire au public,
ou du fait que nous avons l'expertise,
les ressources, et pour certains, l'autorité,
d'accomplir cette mission.
Je ne prétends pas que tous les scientifiques doivent militer.
Faire entendre sa voix entraîne des conséquences concrètes
et parfois pénibles.
Mais dénoncer l'idée, la possibilité si unilatéralement
dans le but de protéger le financement de la recherche,
est un acte de lâcheté intéressé.
Ce ne sont pas des idéaux que nous voulons transmettre à nos étudiants.
Vous pensez sans doute que tout ça, c'est très bien,
mais qu'il est impossible de transformer les cultures d'organisation,
ou d'imprégner l'esprit des étudiants et des professionnels
d'une vision de leur travail en tant que bien public,
de la science au service du public.
Vous avez peut-être raison.
Cette situation ne trouverait-elle pas son origine
dans le fait que nous ne formons pas nos étudiants correctement ?
Quand on observe bien la situation,
notre système d'éducation actuel est davantage concentré sur la création
d'excellents moutons, comme les appelle l'ancien professeur de Yale, Deresiewicz,
des jeunes gens, intelligents et ambitieux,
bien qu'un peu frileux devant les risques, timides et sans but,
et parfois, imbus d'eux-mêmes.
Les enfants, vous savez, ...
on est tombé amoureux des sciences quand on était enfants.
Malgré ça, on passe la plupart de notre temps au lycée et à la fac
à sauter toujours plus haut,
et à faire des choses qui embellissent notre C.V.
au lieu de prendre le temps
de réfléchir à ce qu'on veut faire, et à quelle personne on veut devenir.
Ainsi,
les marques d'empathie chez les étudiants
ont diminué très fortement ces deux dernières décennies,
alors que le narcissisme s'épanouit.
La culture du désengagement se répand également,
divisant les étudiants en ingénierie et le public.
On nous forme pour construire des ponts et résoudre des problèmes complexes,
mais pas comment penser, vivre, ou comment être un citoyen du monde.
Mes années à fac furent une préparation explicite au travail.
Impossible de vous dire combien ce fut étouffant, parfois même douloureux.
Certains croient que la clé pour former de grands ingénieurs et scientifiques,
c'est davantage de formation technique.
C'est possible.
Mais où sont les discussions sur une prise de décision éthiques,
sur la construction de sa personnalité,
ou sur le discernement entre le bien et le mal ?
Voici un projet que j'admire et qui m'est très cher.
Ça s'appelle : « Projet de l'Imagination Héroïque »,
un bébé du Dr Phil Zimbardo,
célèbre pour son expérience de la Prison de Stanford.
Ce programme cherche à former des écoliers partout dans le monde
pour qu'ils se considèrent comme des héros en devenir,
des héros en stage.
Ces jeunes esprits travaillent pour développer compétences et vertus
qui, quand l'opportunité se présente,
peu importe laquelle,
ils agissent et font ce qui est juste.
En d'autres mots,
n'importe qui peut devenir un héros.
Réfléchissons-y un instant.
Pourquoi ne pas faire pareil en sciences et en ingénierie,
en faisant des vertus de l'héroïsme et du service public ?
Car en effet, c'est souvent l'héroisme
qui est l'antidote de l'indifférence publique,
et du mal systémique tel que celui subi par Flint.
Rêvons ensemble !
A quoi pourrait ressembler le scientifique et l'ingénieur du 21ème siècle ?
Des personnes dédiées à maitriser la science
au service de la société,
et conscientes du pouvoir immense
de leur savoir et de leurs décisions.
Des gens qui développent un courage moral en tout temps,
et qui réalisent que les conflits et les controverses
ne sont pas nécessairement mauvais
car notre loyauté ultime va au public et à la Terre.
Ces personnes défendront Flint, comme nous l'avons fait,
non pas pour devenir les sauveurs ou les héros des media,
mais parce qu'ils sont altruistes, justes et méritent notre confiance.
Imaginez cultiver un état d'esprit focalisé sur la communauté,
dans les cours, dans les voyages d'étude, et pendant les activités
académiques et scolaires
afin que ces jeunes esprits restent attachés à leurs idéaux,
en entrant dans la vie professionnelle,
qu'ils soient consultants, académiques, juristes,
ou même futur président d'un pays.
Les plus grands défis de l'humanité sont à venir ;
la contamination de l 'eau est un exemple parmi d'autres.
Nous pourrions utiliser davantage,
non, nous avons un besoin vital de personnes engagées et bienveillantes,
des scientifiques et des ingénieurs préoccupés par le service public,
qui s'efforcent de faire ce qui est juste,
et qui ne s'efforcent pas d'être dociles.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)